from an existentialist perspective
what's the role for standing up to evil
so
i mean i think camus probably had
something to say about these things
because he was a bit of a political
figure like do you have a responsibility
not just for your decisions
but you know if
the world you see around you
is um
going against what you believe somewhere
deep inside is
ethical
do you have a responsibility to stand up
to that even if it costs you your life
or your well-being
you ask from an existential perspective
and there's lots of different
positions that you could have so let me
tell you something in the area of what i
think i might believe which comes out of
this tradition
um
and it's this uh if you live in a
community where
people are being dragged down by the
norms of the community rather than
elevated
then there's two things that you have to
recognize
one is that you bear some responsibility
for that
not necessarily because you chose it
uh maybe you reviled it maybe you were
against it
but there's some way in which we all act
in accordance with the norms of our
culture we all give in to them in some
way or another and if those norms
are broken
then there's some way in which we've
allowed ourselves to be responsible for
for broken norms
we've become responsible for broken
norms and i i do think you have to face
up to that
i think that um let's just take gender
norms maybe the gender norms are broken
maybe the way men and women treat one
another or the way men treat women
is broken you know maybe there's maybe
it is maybe there's i'm not making a
substantive claim i'm just saying you
know lots of people say it is
and if
uh you're in a culture where
uh those norms take root
you you don't get to just isolate
yourself and pull yourself out of the
culture and think i don't have any
responsibility
um that's you're already a part of the
culture even
if you're isolating yourself from it
that's a way of rejecting the
sort of part you play in the culture but
it's not a way of getting
behind it you now you're playing that
role differently you're saying i i don't
i don't i don't want to take
responsibility for what's going on
around me
and that's a way of
taking responsibility by refusing to do
it so i i think we're implicated in
whatever whatever is going on around us
and if we're going to do anything in our
lives we ought to recognize that
recognize that even in situations where
you maybe didn't decide to do it you you
could be part of bringing other people
down
and then
devote yourself to trying to figure out
how to act differently so that the norms
up update themselves uh and i and i
think this is not a a criticism of
people and the alyosha who we mentioned
in the brothers karamazov he's a
character he's a kind of saintly
character
um in the brothers karamazov but that
one crucial moment in his in in that
story
when he realizes how awful he's been
being to someone without ever even
intending to do that it's grushanka
who's this sort of fascinating woman
and she's a very erotic woman she's sort
of sexual and and and alyosha
in my reading of it is kind of attracted
to her
but he's a young kid he's 20 or whatever
and he's kind of embarrassed about it
and he lives in the monastery and he's
thinking maybe he wants to be a priest
and he's kind of embarrassed by it so
what does he do
every time they run across one another
in the street he averts his gaze
and why is he doing that because he's
kind of embarrassed
but how does grishanka experience it
well she knows she's a fallen woman and
she knows that alyosha has this other
position in society so her read on it is
he's passing judgment on me he can see
that he doesn't want to be associated
with me he can see that i'm a fallen
woman he knows that in order to maintain
his purity he's got a reason he's got to
avoid me
that that's not what alyosha intended to
do
but that's the way it's experienced and
so there's this way he comes to
recognize oh my god like what i'm
supposed to do is love people
in dostoevsky's view of things
and what i'm doing instead is dragging
this poor woman down i'm making her life
worse i'm making her feel terrible about
herself and if i actually came to know
her i'd recognize her condition is
difficult she's living a difficult life
she's making hard choices and why don't
i you know why don't i see that in her
face instead of this other thing that's
making me want to avoid her and that's a
huge moment so but the idea is that
we're implicated in bringing other
people down
whether we want to be or not
and that's our condition so
the requirement to understand that is to
be almost to a radical degree be
empathetic and to listen
to the world
you